don't bring anyone love into this also
this is one thing that came in a lot
over the weekend was are you gonna 69 at
69 we did this thing my dad turned 70
earlier this year that's my favorite
thing we had a big family reunion and my
mom you know my mom with Florida yeah
that's when you went too far my mom's
Peruvian and she doesn't she's not up on
any of the lingo or anything so at this
big dinner I asked my mom I said you
know dad's turning 70 tomorrow are you
gonna 69 him tonight and she was like
what she didn't understand so we were
all laugh and make and just joke about
how you know it just just make fun of
her how naive she is right so we told
people on our podcast that you should do
the same thing ask your mom if she'll 69
your dad when he turns 70 and they've
been doing it in videotaping the
reaction pass out a plan I'm gonna play
a few of them for example the the
milestone like it 17 70th birthday right
so when Tracy is about to turn 70 his
last night of being 69 years old would
you 69 him oh shit
No yeah Tracy you look a little
stone-cold in the face there mom mom do
you think when Danny's about to turn 70
do you think to celebrate that's a like
69 that zach the first one was that's
Austin from Florida here's Josh and
Sarah had a question this is a prayer
prayer thanks mom and dad mom on the
night before I check the pops turn 70
years old yes absolutely
we 69 just where you got here
[Laughter]
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay penicillin
[Music]
[Laughter]
what did she say what she said your
ideas
she said my pussy foot pussy the lips
will be too long hanging down covering
your eyes that's what you do just take
the pussy lips and put them over your
eyes like you're flying on JetBlue you
lick that little Buffalo mo you think
you two are gonna be together when we
turn 70 are you guys gonna still be
together when he turned 70 night before
his 70th birthday you guys gonna 69 last
time she goes why does it have to end
one last
[Music]